most Rescuers and experts at Niagara
consider unprotected survival stories to
be blind luck but there are some
strategies that might just save your
life if for any reason you find yourself
hurdling 109 kmph in freezing cold water
towards the edge of a 57 M
drop the first thing you need to
remember just before you go over is to
take a really deep breath when you reach
the bottom there will be so much water
swirling around you not to mention the
intense pressure of the water falling
from above that you could easily
suffocate so taking a big gulp of air
before your fall could buy you some time
you'll also want to take precautions to
protect your head if you can Orient
yourself so that you fall feet first
then you'll want to wrap your arms
around your head with your elbows over
your nose and clench your eyes and mouth
shut as tightly as possible